alexis st pierre a installé ses
décorations de noël
un peu plus tôt qu'à l'habitude cette
année une injection de lumière en cette
époque plutôt sombre c'est le réconfort
c'est nos traditions si nos valeurs
c'est pas tous les gens qui vont passer
noël en famille donc si je peux donner
un peu de joie que ça soit quelques
secondes ou quelques minutes par jour
tant mieux l'engouement pour les
décorations de noël se fait sentir dans
les quincailleries chez ce détaillant de
quartier des ventes ont pratiquement
doublé comparativement à l'an dernier
les gens auraient misé leur intérieur
leur état de bonheur si on joue à la vie
de tous les jours les consommateurs qui
veulent mettre la main sur certains
produits comme les sapins artificiels et
les lumières devront faire vite
c'est très difficile d'avoir du stock en
ce moment de la marchandise parce que il
y en a plein les entrepôts c'est la même
histoire dans l'ensemble des
quincailleries qui ont commandé leurs
décorations de noël de nombreux mois al
avance avant même la pandémie la plupart
des approvisionnements vienne doutre m'a
particulièrement des pays asiatiques
donc on n'a pas le temps le luxe de se
réapprovisionner puis personne ne savait
en mars que comment se comporterait le
consommateur dans ce magasin où noël et
la spécialité
quelques clients se laissent emporter
par la magie des fêtes
on va faire ça avec avec les enfants va
mettre un petit peu de lumière dans nos
vies un peu plus tôt cette année
ironie du sort la boutique ne profite
pas de l'engouement pour les décorations
de noël
si ventes ont plongé de plus de 80% des
gens ne font pas le déplacement pour
venir au vieux-montréal sachant qu'il y
a rien d'autre à faire dans le secteur
normalement quand les gens venaient ici
autant d'effets à être régulier il y
avait des activités
s'il n'y a plus de décoration dans les
quincailleries vous en trouverez
probablement ici ici olivier bâche un
réseau canada montréal